[Musique]
un petit message ici depuis l'aéro club
de louda sur une piste que je connais
bien puisque je n'ai utilisé quelquefois
un message de soutien aux lèvres au club
voilà on en a besoin c'est une activité
sportive c'est l'activité qui fait rêver
parce qu'on a besoin évidemment de
former un jour des pilotes pour l'avenir
parce qu'on a besoin de pilotes en
sécurité civile on a besoin de pilotes
pour la sécurité tout court on a besoin
de pilotes pour les transports
sanitaires comme on a pu le voir depuis
quelques mois c'est bien souvent dans
les aéroclubs connaissent les vocations
et donc c'est pour ça que je tenais à
leur témoigner mon soutien et puis plus
particulièrement évidemment ici à l'aéro
club de loudun un mot évidemment général
de soutien à l'aviation civile qui on a
aussi besoin c'est un secteur économique
fort ce jeudi matin alain pichon a été
élu président du syndicat mixte de
l'aéroport de poitiers biard c'est un
aéroport qui contribue à l'attractivité
de notre département qui contribuent au
développement du tourisme qui a des
lignes aussi particulière utile pour
l'économie vers lyon la rochelle utile
aussi pour le touriste vers ajaccio et
montpellier et puis utile à tous ceux
qui font les liaisons avec les îles
britanniques donc voila c'était un
message de soutien à tous ceux qui
rêvent de voler à très vite
[Musique]